[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships I'm Ken Coleman
joined by the incomparable the lovely
Rachel Cruz the phone number is
2258 825 5225 Rachel will be taking your
money questions I'll chime in if she
lets me we'll see how that can you
always want your thoughts can I'm sure
you do and uh we'll also take your work
questions so uh your income is your
greatest wealth building tool your
income multiple incomes is the best way
to get out of debt and get through the
rest of the baby steps so if you're
feeling stuck you're not where you want
to be in your work life and your
financial life is being affected I'm
here to help you on that as well so
we'll take those calls let's get right
to it Ross is joining us now at Houston
Texas Ross how can we
help hello Hello Ross you're live on the
Ramsey show what's
up awesome awesome how are youall doing
today we're having a
blast it's really good to get through to
y'all I have a I've been trying for a
couple months but well today is your day
what is your
question so uh we kind of got in a
predicament where my girlfriend got in a
wreck not too long ago is she okay year
ago and yes she was fine she uh almost
bit through her bottom lip but she's
doing good all healed up and everything
um but we ended up
purchasing a vehicle after that uh out
of spite she went and got a challenger
and then uh about six months later we
found out she was pregnant so now we
have another vehicle and we just kept
rolling bad equity in this one vehicle
and it is now has a loone for about 38
$37,000 and it's only worth about 20 22
wow um it's got a
$664 payment per month on it and then uh
I also downsized from a truck to a
smaller vehicle and got a loan on it
like a smart person and
um uh it's uh got a note for 405 407 per
month and I was just wondering uh like
what y'all would
well I have an idea of what yall would
do but um more the question is how can I
get my girlfriend on board to sell this
car if not both cars okay how much is it
to lower our notes yes okay Ross um how
much do you on your
truck uh I do not have a truck anymore I
downsized to a car oh you okay and and
how much is is on that car
then uh
21 $22,000 okay perfect um how much does
she make a
year um I don't know the exact on both
but I know our total together because I
put I have the every dollar app so um it
just shows a total of what our annual
income would be and it's 64 and that div
down to
about that five five grand a month okay
um well hold on we can answer Rachel's
question what do you make out of the 64
what do you
make uh I make around 30
okay okay so you guys are essentially
making about the same amount of money
correct yes and I have a quick question
for Rachel it's I'm going to ask him but
this is for you because you're walking
through this I'm just curious you w the
question is how do we get her on board
but you said that she got in a car
accident then she bought a I think you
said a Dodge well he said we bought a do
I make sure Ross's number is I'm going
to make sure your name Ross is not on
her car that too but I also want to know
what it means by we did it out of Spike
cuz I want to know where her head heads
at on this whole
situation well she got she wrecked into
a guard rail and then she didn't want to
have to pay for the damages so she just
thought about getting a brand new
vehicle and it wasn't it wasn't brand
new it was used but it was new to her
and so that helps me with her mindset on
all this okay um wow Ross is your name
on her
car the newest one yes okay all right
Ross so let's just have like a high
picture chat here for a second um
because your whole language you're
acting like you're married okay your
names are on each other's debts you're
combining income and all of it and what
the the what what can happen very
quickly because we talk to people all
the time on this show Ross sadly is that
you have there's there's no legal
binding like when like if you guys were
legally married then the risk then is
you know it's it's somewhat mitigated
because if a divorce happens or there's
separation right there there's legal
action that can be taken none of that
can be taken in this situation and so I
want you to be very cautious and I know
you guys have a baby together and all of
it I mean you're acting like you're
married so so you you have to be so
careful financially Ross so careful and
I would recommend keeping everything
separate because you are not legally
married and this ends up becoming a
complete mess and so are you going to
get married do you think that I mean
obviously I'm hoping she's the one you
guys are doing life together you you
have a baby together like as marriage in
the picture um the the the bad thing is
we don't have enough money saved up to
have them a wedding so different
question Ross you get a marriage license
down at the courthouse right yes I want
I want to do I do want to get married
but uh the stipulation is a wedding and
because I've already gave like the the
JP office you know run at it and it was
not taken very well how old are you
guys uh I'm I'm 21 and she is uh about
to be 23 okay okay so stipulation she
has laid a stipulation out she's 23 she
wants her wedding she's a 23 year old
girl I mean this is I get it's not
surprising me I get it but it's not what
needs to happen no it doesn't you're
right and I and this is not me rushing
you if you guys don't need to get
married you don't need to get married
but I don't want you to keep playing
like you're married especially with
money so
Ross oh man okay so the question is how
does he get her on board I want to know
your take on this cuz you do have a
female point of view too she lik the car
she is pregnant or is the baby already
here uh yes he is 8 months old oh he's
month so she's a new mom she likes the
car and you have brought up the idea of
selling it and she didn't like that at
all uh correct did you tell her why you
think you should sell
it um I told her that we could all she
sees is the money on top so we're not
going to be making any money off of of
it so she sees a vehicle that we're
going to have to pay on even though we
don't have a nice vehicle right yeah but
also you'd be you
know paying on be on the track to paying
off debt very quickly because like I did
it and with the little amount that we
saved the most we saved on a single
month was $800 and we threw that to the
smallest loan which is my car loan to
try to do the debt snowball and uh it
just it fluctuates so much especially
with our son because he has like he's
going to have some surgeries coming up
because he's got to get tubes put in his
ear and it just fluctuates when you have
a baby so sometimes we save $600
sometimes that and totally and you know
yeah so well let me just say this that's
the kind of predicament for sure well
you guys I mean you guys have gosh you
know 58 thou close to what you make in a
year in car loans and it's just too much
R you guys can't afford these cars so if
you're underwater on the first one I
would probably sell it I think I'd
rather have $155,000 loan with a you
know a beater car uh than a
$37,000 loan making what you guys make
and then with your car rossing 21,000
and you're making $ 36,000 you don't you
can't afford these cars so you're going
to have to sell them get some beaters
take a loan out for the difference it's
not going to be fun it's going to be
uncomfortable but from my financial
standpoint that's what the numbers show
me Ross you got to show her a monthly
savings how you get out get in the
details cast Vision it's the only way
you're going to get her on board this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus A5 ,000 seller guarantee gives your
offer the best chance of being accepted
the home buyer Edge from Church Hill
gives you an advantage over those other
guys go to Churchill mortgage.com today
to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
colen I'm joined by Rachel Cruz and we
are here for you this hour the phone
number is toll-free you can jump in atle
8825 5225 that's Triple 8 825 5225 the
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
the 19 home service Brands Nationwide
the network of local service pros on
neighborly decom can help you with just
about anything you need in and around
your home incidentally neighborly was
was was founded to solve problems like
Ken Coleman because I can't do anything
I you and George camel are like a two
peas in a pod we are neighborly Prime
customers our poor wives we can't do
anything around house you know do you
know George on this show said something
about um table saws and he's like I mean
you guys go spend $1,000 on table saws
he got lit up cuz everyone's like
they're like 100 to he thinks they're
like $1,200 yeah right right right well
you know again I'm not even sure he
knows what a table saw is he just heard
it circular saw yeah he has no idea but
nonetheless uh if you're like me please
visit neighborly decom Ramsey to find
out more and improve your marriage all
right today's question it's a long one
get ready everyone it buckle up we got
Barry in New Jersey is my wife a
princess or do I need an attitude change
yes and yes all right let's get question
their numbers we have followed your baby
steps in our debt free but the house our
net worth is 1.6 million we owe 80,000
on the house it's worth 700,000 we're 50
years old my incomes W 20
125,000 every year early in our marriage
my wife made over a 100,000 but we had
two kids and later we had two more we
made the decision for her to be home and
homeschool the kids all the way through
High School huge sacrifice both agreed
it was best for our family now fast
forward 20 years the kids are grown
we're doing well our lives and our
marriage are great but my wife is still
not working I have asked her to just
work to knock out the mortgage to take
that off my back and to help us build a
gap fund so I can retire a little early
she has shown little effort at finding
something and is not super motivated uh
we make plenty to live on but I've
noticed some of our budget drift as she
has more time on her hands and isn't
needing to spend devoted time to our
kids with schooling is she a princess
for not wanting to go back to work or do
I just need to suck it up and change my
attitude and be grateful for the fact
that she doesn't have to work
I know I need jerk I want you to go
first because I have a very clear answer
uh I think he needs an attitude change I
think she's being a princess she worked
hard with the kids she's a stay-at home
now wife he's doing fine financially
they got 80k on the house they're going
to pay it off she's 50 plus years old
she's enjoying her life I agree
but but I'm not mad at her I'm not
either but what do you say in fact I'm
going to stay out of this and just ask a
question okay let's say that uh Barry's
wife her name is Mary just for fun okay
and let's say you and Mary go to tea or
whatever you would do and and she says
my husband Barry has asked me to go back
to work it's the same scenario sure and
she says to you we're fine all the
things you just said yeah but I
understand he wants to knock it out blah
blah blah blah blah these are he wants
me to go back to work and I I just don't
want to what should I say to him how
should we handle this what would your
advice be to your friend Mary about her
husband
Barry Mary and
Barry uh I would say I could understand
where he's coming from I can see more
for him wanting to retire early and
wanting to get out of the work and stuff
I see that more plausible and
understandable for some reason than even
the house I know but what you say to her
because he's clearly brought this up to
her Y and she she's not moving f so I
would I would ask
her uh what is it that keeps you from
not working meaning like is it that you
don't have a thing that you're
passionate about that you want to do uh
is it that you just logically have come
to a conclusion that y'all are going to
be fine like you're going to pay off the
house soon yeah he will retire at a
decent age there's no need for this
urgency at this point in our lives um so
I would ask her those questions and then
I would have her I would I would want
her to ask him you know hey what what's
really like what is going on what's more
pressing
do you get frustrated that I'm just home
is that bother you do you think I'm like
you know mean I know cuz some resentment
could be building on his end could it be
the budget drift so he's like if she
works then she's going to keep her you
know she can't like and obviously she
can't go and just do whatever she want
like we have to have limits and
boundaries in life but it doesn't sound
like she's out of control not at all and
if they had two car payments and $15,000
a credit card debt she's she got she has
to get back to work all right so I want
you to keep on this cuz you're getting
this there but let me in interject on
behalf of you get us there do you know
do you know where we're going well I
yeah but where you were going I wanted
you to tell us what you would tell her
because I think this is a getting on the
same page you're great at that you're
very intentional in your life with
Winston and so here's my only take I
think he sees her as potential income
and he's got some stress and he's got
some urgency over a goal and he look
he's looking at her in this case wrongly
sure bar were with me I go I understand
what you see
you see potential inome that's not being
maxed out and you're going come on babe
yeah that's what I think he's feeling so
then how do she that's what I'm so I
just wanted to throw that in there so
what would you tell her cuz there's some
stress on his end uh there is and I just
wonder on her end hey is is there other
ways that I can help contribute to
lowering that stress with me not having
to go back to work like would it make
you feel better and and if agreed on a
budget and I actually stuck to my word
right cuz if the budget's a drift then
there is a level of like someone's not
keeping their word which cannot it's not
great um so I would have those
conversations but I also think that
there's like a a reasonableness for him
to see yeah y'all you guys are doing
fine yeah well if anytime someone
mentions twice the same phrase is she a
princess me thinks that Barry thinks
that she's a princess and what he means
by that is not the compliment it's like
you got it good babe I've been out
busting it yes you did your PR so I I
would say to Barry hey dude I'm guessing
there's already been a lot of tension
around this and you got to change your
tenor and how you're going at this cuz
if you're asking us twice and you and a
thing that you know may get red on the
air is she a princess that tells me you
are feeling some resentment towards her
that's got to get fixed that's that's
more of the underlying issue and I do
think sometimes spouses because our
spouse is the closest person in our
lives they are the ones that we can just
kind of like yeah you know say it all
give it all whatever um but I do think
the intentionality and you're great at
this Ken asking questions I think in
Winston and I have kind of gotten in
this Rhythm too instead of just say of
telling right you do that I want you to
do asking questions actually get to know
your spouse on that level of what's
what's really going on and that takes
some intentionality uh but I think
getting to the root of all of this is
key the root for her why does she not
want to stick to the budget the root for
her why does she not want to go back to
work like like what what what's going on
within her Y and then for him too what
what is going on I love you bring this
up because we know there's all kinds of
tension around money issues this is a
really great conversation one of the
things I learned from a coach years ago
that I was getting trained by as I was
getting into this type of work where I
get to coach people they told me to
always ask what questions not why
questions you hear this in a lot of
therapy like if you're doing marriage
counseling a good therapist we we have a
mutual friend who we did some work with
both of us individually and it's was
like don't ask why questions ask what so
in this case Barry needs to get to a
question where he goes I've I've
mentioned to you that you could work um
what is keeping you from pursuing this
what are you concerned about what are
and allow her to share her voice yes and
not be defensive because it's like why
haven't you applied for something yikes
right she's immediately on the defensive
and unable to do anything but defend
herself yeah the finger pointing doesn't
get anyone anywhere yeah that's right
and that's and that is hard so yeah and
and usually too I have found Canon life
in all my years it's there's usually a
balance is she's probably not a
full-blown crazy princess over here oh
no but could there be some time you know
could there be some things here and
there that she could do to help it
relieve some stress sure and for him
right like I think there's always this
like there's there's usually a middle
ground my guy Barry he's a little up
tight and so a little advice to Barry is
hey you know what why don't you go take
on a second job go go enjoy your life
no I'm going to tell him to go put up
and she's like and so Mary's like well
Barry why aren't you home he's like well
I just really want to knock this out and
then she starts to go well why do you
feel they need to do this yeah that
could be a little a little passive
aggressive way to do it but it's better
than what he's doing now by emailing the
second largest Radio Show in the country
and asking is my wife a princess by the
way I don't know if her name is Mary I
just think it' be really cool if Barry's
wife was mared Bary Barry and Mary can
you imagine ladies and gentlemen I
introduced to you Mr and Mrs Barry and
Mary whatever I don't know folks the
drugs are kicking in they'll be ready by
we get when we get back from the
commercial break it's ADHD it's a real
thing folks the struggle's real this is
the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loan and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y ref i.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey welcome back to the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me and
we are taking your calls on your money
your work and your relationships 8825
5225 8 825 5225 Grand Rapids Michigan is
where Ethan is Ethan how can we
help Hi how are you good sir what's
going
on hi um so I am a 22-year-old college
senior I'm I'm looking to propose to my
girlfriend in the next couple months but
when we get married she will have about
$70,000 of student debt and so I was
just curious on some ways to prepare
myself to take on that thatb when we get
married in a yeares well we start with a
stiff drink and then we get no I'm
kidding that's terrible advice I'm
kidding I'm joking just making sure
everybody's paying atten a little
cocktail and you're good no I mean we've
got the baby steps but they usually work
better when you're inheriting debt with
a stiff drink uh so you have no debt at
all no I don't okay all right so tell us
emotionally where you are I would just
love to know this like cuz you're
calling to ask this question how how is
it hitting you knowing that you're going
to marry this gal and you're starting
with 70 grand in
debt um a little because I don't have
any debt a little uneasy um we're also
moving to Iowa I took a job out there
for after I graduate um are you GNA be
making kind of the um pre-tax I'll
making $69,000 post tax with a 5%
contribution to a four 401 cable 55 and
does she expect to work as well
yes she has one more semester of college
and then she'll be um getting a
full-time job in what
field she has a business degree um she's
not exactly sure what field she likes to
get into though okay so what would
starting salary yeah what do you think
35 40 40 I would say yeah 40ish yeah
probably in the in the 40ish range yeah
I wanted to give Rachel those numbers
she'll walk you through what you're
going to do here but this is doable yeah
um I mean and I'm assuming the debt is
student love Lo
correct yes only student loans okay yeah
so here's like if there is a you know
the positive side to this Ethan for me
cuz going into a relationship we talk
about this a lot with couples that are
seriously dating or engaged entering
marriage that the money conversation it
needs to be had and obviously you guys
have had that you know what her debt is
and I think the most important part
where my uneasiness would be not really
is the dollars because it's going to be
a journey y'all will get out of debt we
can look at the numbers in a second um
but I think where my uneasiness would be
is her value is when it comes to money
when it comes to debt right so if you
told me it was
$70,000 half in a car loan half in
credit card debt because she just loves
to go and shop and do whatever she wants
to do regardless of what money is like
that's not her right that that would
tend to feel like okay we have a
behavior issue there that could probably
you know create a lot of conflict in
marriage let's talk about that but this
is student loan debt and it is what it
is you know what I'm saying so like the
even the types the type of debt is
different so from a value standpoint um
relationally I think I would have a
little bit of piece of just like okay
this isn't a behavior problem per se and
just making sure that you guys are on
the same page with debt like never again
we're not we're not going to use debt
going forward so that's more of like
that that Baseline to get to and then
when you look at the numbers Ethan um I
would not contribute to your 401k I
would put that 5% back in your paycheck
to put towards the 70,000 so I would do
nothing I would I would literally do
nothing with my income except pay for
Necessities cuz you guys are in college
so I want you to keep living like you're
in college keep living like broke
college students for a few years where
you just got your your rent uh CU I
don't want you to buy a house so rent
somewhere you guys you know eat cheap no
vacations I mean you guys are really
going to buckle down probably work a
side hustle or two uh work weekends like
do some things you guys have to do
because um the good thing is too in Iowa
like you're not moving to to the Bay
Area or Miami or you know some like High
Cost of Living area um so for you guys
together I'm like yeah I mean if you're
making 110 together um you know you guys
could you you really could knock this
out in two years Ethan I mean like you
guys could really say together hey we're
going to live on we're going to live on
55,000 and you could get this 70 paid
off in 18 months absolutely right I the
way I like to look at things like this
because I know it's really scary Ethan
is let's say you do what Rachel said and
we try to knock it out in two years that
is $33,000 a month so between the two of
you with no kids maybe you're working a
second job and you're living like
college students as Rachel said could
you put $3,000 a month towards the debt
if he can't that's okay but $3,000 a
month towards the debt you're out in two
years I me excuse me you're out in uh
yeah that's exactly right so so you it's
it's it's can we get this done the
answer is unequivocally yes the the
question then is how quickly is she on
board by the way with getting after
it I've mentioned to her that I'd like
to pay it off as quickly as possible um
and kind of have a tight budget and
things like that rect down and created a
budget or anything like that um she was
a little uneasy about it but I think she
saw the value in it well so the next
step is again you guys need to do this
together yeah you guys got to sit down
and go if we make this and we start
laying this out if we put 2,000 a month
toward it that's 24,000 a year so that's
going to take us three you know you just
have to get real with the numbers it is
intimidating for anybody when you show
up and you go hey babe I want to knock
the 70 grand out as fast as possible you
didn't tell her
how you know yeah it can feel
overwhelming to point yeah you know yep
yeah so yeah y'all sit down run the
numbers and look at it and and here's
the deal and Ethan like and you can't
force this upon her there's so many
questions of like how do I get my spouse
on boarded I'm like at the end of the
day they're an individual person like
they're going to have to decide but my
encouragement so if she listens to this
call my encouragement would be the
tighter you guys could lock arms and be
such a unified Force against the 70,000
the faster you do it Ethan y'all are
going to be 24 years old two years into
marriage no debt have an incredible way
of how you set your life up and you get
to continue on right I like there
there's such an upside to it and I think
you'll see the the benefit not only
relationally when you do that but also
financially but it but it does take both
to kind of lock arms and say we're doing
this and and and I'll stress this and I
always hate to put like an age of like
well y'all are young so easier cuz I
know life is hard for everyone right at
different
stages but I think it is easier now
Ethan than having kids and one of y'all
like having to figure out like child
care and I mean like there's so many
other dynamics that start to happen in
life you guys are at the prime the prime
just to do it just to do it and all your
friends are getting their new jobs like
nobody you know it's just if you're
going to sacrifice a time this is this
is literally the perfect time to do it
and please hear what she said rent like
don't buy a house don't buy new cars I
know you're you're going to be adulting
you guys are going to be doing pretty
well financially but getting through
this debt and getting an emergency fund
before you start to really get to the
next phase of Life Rachel could not be
any more correct Ethan it's worth it but
you're going to have to cast a vision
you know don't tell her what we're doing
tell her what you want to do why you
want to do it and then you better be
able to show her how and and hold on the
line Ean because we'll pick up and give
you guys Financial Peace University this
is our nine lesson course and every
dollar premium so just to give you some
tools to to walk through together so you
guys watch these videos together it's a
very romantic date night instead of
Netflix watch Financial Peace University
but but start these conversations sit
down and do a mock budget of like hey
let's just dream wst and I do this we're
like let's just dream for a second once
you're out of school and we're both
working like what what cuz honestly you
feel rich like I remember when Wednesday
I when we graduated college and got our
first full-time jobs you're like what
like this is this is amazing we both
made like 42 Grands like you know I mean
like it wasn't like we made a lot a lot
of money combined it does so in start to
kind of feel those numbers and just see
where you guys are going when you can
paint that picture as clearly as
possible it makes it you know it makes
it realistic it makes it fun it makes it
doable all of it but um but yeah but
we're excited for you think congrats too
on the how confident are you that she's
going to say yes when you popped the
question
99% Oh I thought y'all were already
engaged my bad sorry I thought were no
that's why I asked the question no not
not yet he's 99% sure uh I'd like to
work on that 1% I don't know what's but
I feel like that's a great would you
ever go into a proposal if you feel less
than
99% no I personally can't deal with
rejection so I'd have to have I'd have
to be it'd have to be a
lock and the way he said it he was kind
of like 99% I don't know man I'd work on
that a little bit slow down on the Deb
talk
whoa oh one one uh more quick question
that I do have okay super fast we got 30
seconds go all right while in this time
after I graduate until we get married
should I be saving up money to make a
lump sum contribution to her debt don't
pay on anything on her debt until you're
legally married once you guys are
married take your lump sum throw it at
the student loan debt great question
question all right Ethan we're rooting
for you buddy put a ring on it better be
a romantic proposal if it's 99% we got
to go extra on the Romantic ask you know
you need that extra emotion to get that
1% in there I'm just telling you this is
advice he didn't call for but I had to
give him this is the Ramsey
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40% off everything sitewide
go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me and we are
here to help you win in your money life
also your work life and in your
relationships money working
relationships they all uh have a way of
just kind of fitting together when
things are working and opposing each
other when things are not and speaking
of money uh we found at ramsy that if
you're going to win in money no matter
what baby step you're on the budget it's
it's the thing that powers everything
it's as John Maxwell once said it's a
budget is telling your money where to go
and to that end Rachel we've got some
incredible stuff we're doing you are
going to be offering something that's
kind of fun that will help people if
they feel like oh I get it it makes
sense but I'm just I'm not good at it
I'm scared of it whatever it is tell us
about that yeah so we're we've been
doing these every dollar webinars um and
thousands of like six to eight thousand
people sign up for each one which is
just incredible so uh I have one that
I'm hosting on Monday at 11:30 central
time so if you go to everydollar.com
budgeting uh you can sign up there or
you can sign up and we can send you the
recording after but we really want to
walk people through how to do a budget
on a very practical standpoint because
there's a lot of people that push
against the idea of budgeting so we'll
kind of like go through some of those um
push backs but then also walk through
hey here's what it looks like to budget
and here's the benefits of it we do some
live Q&A so we answer questions but it's
about an hour long it's free it's really
helpful so again if you're new to
budgeting or have questions or just want
to hang out on Monday at 11:30 Central
Time go to every.com budgeting and there
it is all right let's get to the phones
Hartford Connecticut is where GE is
hanging out George how can we
help hey how you doing Canon Rachel um
so um I you know consider me and my wife
are right now pretty well off but
however you know with the economy in
today's stage I'm being a very frugal
person or someone call it being cheap um
my wife is the kind of person where she
prefer take a big vacation every year uh
when I say big vacation we're talking
about probably like six seven
000 um and I'm the kind of person you
know I can go 10 15 years without taking
a vacation right so and I just want to
know in my financial stage right now
can't should I be able to or should I be
a little lose with my um you know my
money or should I keep the way I have
been doing it sure okay couple quick
questions for us so yeah so you said you
guys are well off what does that mean
give us your financial
picture okay so I wrote down some of the
numbers so right now we have a combined
income of
$210,000 uh mind you that's in conate
and um we have a combined of uh
retirement saving that's between 401k
and Roth rough IRA between the two of us
of
$315,000 um I also have a
$10,000
529 uh educational saving account for my
children
um what else how much you guys make a
year oh 210 between the oh I'm sorry I
did write that down I apologize so
you've been doing these uh six6 to
$7,000 summer vacations yes or she wants
to start doing them so we did won uh
last year and I'm I'll be honest with
you I'm absolutely hooked right I wanted
I want to go back um but then I wake up
from reality like oh I can't do this you
know I need to keep saving my money
because eventually we want to buy a
bigger house you know and do you guys
what do you guys owe on your current
house uh I owe
110,000 okay and how what other debt do
you have I have zero debt okay what kind
of money do you guys have saved that's
non-retirement
uh I have $60,000 in CD right now and I
have 20,000 25,000 cash in my bank right
now okay how long does it take you to
save up for the $6 to $7,000 vacation
that you said you could do without but
now you're
hooked George how long does it take you
to save up to 7,000 you're a budget guy
man you're all over it yeah how long so
if I if I want to save it if I put on my
mind and I for two I can save up you
know in maybe three months right and
what's the benefit George of taking your
wife and the kids on the six to $7,000
vacation that by the way you're hooked
on well so the thing is right I'm I'm
you know I'm no problem taking it but
what if right there's a lot of what if
you didn't answer my question what are
the benefits of taking your wife and
kids on this6 to $7,000 vacation that
you can easily cash flow and save up for
in a three-month period what are the
benefits you happy wife happy life okay
great uh not to mention you said you
were hooked on it George it's good it's
good for everybody now take me to the
worst case scenario that this 6 to 7,000
and I want to stay with this number
Rachel cuz that's the number you've
given us George give me this the the
thing that you're so worried about
happening where the 6 to 7,000 you're
spending on the vacay put you in a bad
spot well like I'm trying to say right I
I'm currently we are saving um to buy a
bigger house right uh we are trying to
actually move to a different state to
you know buy a bigger and nicer much
nicer house and um you know want to make
sure I have what's your goal what's see
you're not answering my question George
you're like a politician on a Sunday
Morning Show so I'm going to act like
the host so listen listen I'm trying to
get you somewhere okay so how much are
you trying to save every year to get
into the new house what's the goal
because I know you know it what is it I
want to save somewhere between 4 to
$50,000 every year all right so am I
understanding that you want to save 40
to 50,000 every year am I understanding
that you can't hit that number 40 being
the low number because you're spending
six to seven on the
vacation oh man this is another result I
was hoping for what it means is I got
you cuz what I think I hear you say is
you can save the 40 to 50 a year and
cash flow the vacation am I right
georgea George
go you know my wife standing next to me
good tell her what's her name what's her
name is she
listening she she is she you know Mary
Mary you're going on vacation Mary
Rachel and Kim say you are going on
vacation every
year you know I was I was hoping that
you guys are gonna take my side and be
like you know you should do you know
years George we actually did take your
side you can do both is what Ken's
saying yeah you get to go on vacation
and also George and here's the thing
okay and I think I could I could get a
little bit more on George's side I could
like empathize with you a little bit
more if George you're like hey here's
our goal here's this we could be in two
years earlier and she really wants this
she wants both like we're trying to
really Recon the the main the main
reason you said to Ken when he first
asked you was why he says what if
something happens what if the world go
and it's like that hasn't happened
George you're living in a fear that has
not happened if that's the reality then
we will change it and we probably won't
go on the 6 to 7,000 trip that year
because the world is collapsed if the
world's going to hell in a hand basket
I'm going on vacation I tell you right
now I'm going to be on the beach when it
all goes down all right that's how I'm
if the worst case scenario happens
pulling back your lifestyle may be a
reality and that's what a lot of people
find you guys have gotten out of debt
you have your emergency fund you make a
great income you have savings and retire
like you're doing everything right and
you have the ability there is margin
there for you guys to enjoy your life
George you have to enjoy your life Mary
is Mary right there George is Mary still
there no she actually just left to a
meeting I was gonna ask Mary where you
guys are going this
year actually we going to uh kin Mexico
last year and then I'm just absolutely
hooked um one thing I was I was want to
say is I think uh what it is this the
lifestyle I grew up with right I grew up
poor that's right that's right right in
my family I never went on vacation in
fact we barely L the state at all right
um so you know I still buy my clothes
from Goodwell if I buy clothes right and
um I'm G take you on a shopping trip
George you and me pal J crew it's going
to be great I know but that's a
legitimate thing George we do find that
you talk about that you wrote a book
about money Styles yes know yourself
know your money and you go back to
Childhood so much of how we're shaped
our fears our dreams all of that is
because of the emot State or the true
Financial State of our household growing
up so it's very real that fear but it's
not the it's not reality George so
you're not you're not that little boy
anymore living in that scenario you're a
grown man who's done really well with
your family and that's the state you
have to live in speaking of States
wherever you go on vacation George we'd
like you to send us a postcard from you
and Mary to Rachel and I uh Ramy
Solutions care of Rachel Cruz Ken
Coleman we'd love to see your postcard
it's going to be great this is the Ramy
show
[Music]
n
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey show where
we help you win in your life
specifically in your money life your
work life and in your relationship life
the phone number to jump in is 88255 225
it's a full toll-free number not full
free tollfree actually made up a word
there it's always fun when you're hurry
live tollfree
8825 5225 I'm Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz is
about to make fun of me go ahead well
toll-free I feel like that's like what
we used to hear back in the day like on
TV when it was like a call for this I'm
an old radio guy there's a yeah the
internet everybody everybody pretty much
knows is toll-free you're going to give
us a PO Box to write two yeah and make
sure you go to
www. ramsy solutions.com if you're a new
listener we've got our a new listener
survey that'll help you catch up
remember that's
www do just kidding AOL keyword ramsy
AOL that's right I don't know why I say
that I think it's an old radio hat
tollfree nobody even knows what that
means what is that do I have to pay a
toll to call I know it means it's a free
call just Grandpa Ken all right have you
had enough see if Shelby are you are you
feel good about yourself I feel good I
feel good grandpa move on good thank you
very much uh Shelby is is on the line in
Sacramento Shelby how can we
help hi um thanks for taking my call um
so my question is about when do you
decide to put paying debt on the back
burner I guess um I have a lifestyle
right now that's completely
unsustainable I have a three-month-old
and a 15-month-old I have no child care
and I am also working part-time 25 hours
for a week from home and balancing those
two things has been impossible and um
current my kids are really suffering
honestly sorry um because my job is so
demanding that I not there for that the
way I want to be and I want to leave my
job but my job is paying for our debt
repayment you know almost in full um and
so if I were to quit my job and be at
home with my kids full-time um it would
significantly delay our ability to pay
off our debt and so I'm kind of just I
feel kind of Trapped one way or another
okay well Rachel I'll walk you through
the numbers on this but I but you guys
can still get through this but you can't
get through it period If you're burning
out emotionally I am I know we can tell
and uh I just wanted to tell you you're
enough you're doing fine you're busting
it you guys will figure this out um but
uh there was a season of life where
Stacy was was working and to help bring
in extra income I was going for it and
my income was was much lower I took a
strategic sacrifice and we went through
something similar like this and she was
trying to help and which we had three
kids under the age of three and I got to
tell you you know I I I was an idiot for
not realizing it sooner and I just said
hey I'll make up the difference but what
matters right now is that you the nerve
center the CEO you know the mama the
wife you have got to just be home taking
care of the kiddos so I certainly
empathize with what you're feeling I
just want to tell you you're not a bad
mom those kids are okay you've not done
any damage to them up to this point
that's all I wanted to say thank you I
appreciate that so good okay so Shelby
what uh how much are you bringing in
with your job um I bring in about 2,000
after taxes it's sometimes I work a
little bit more but that's kind of the
average right now okay and what about
your
husband um he brings home about 5200
okay and how much debt do you guys have
we have 30,000 um it's just uh two cars
I shouldn't say just still 30,000 in
debt um with two cars um and currently
if I were to continue working we'd be
able to pay off all of our debt in a
year okay okay um curious real quick
what does he do for a
living He is a construction design
manager I'm so sorry I don't know if you
can hear my kids you're fine you're fine
you're talking to two people who have
three kids each we've been there done
that it sounds like it same place at our
house all the time screaming and crying
you're fine you're fine all the time yes
um but so my husband is a um Team lead
technically for a construction design
company um he is in the process of
requesting a raise but it hasn't
happened yet and we're not sure if
that's going to be possible is he pretty
handy
though um so he uh handy no so he does
uh computer work he is not a
construction guy oh she's like Noe join
the club cuz you're you're talking to
the chief non-h handy guy right here I
can barely change the toilet paper know
it's it's I have to get instructions I I
do my own oil changes my husband can't
oh there you go hate Shelby you're a
really sweet lady please don't tell
anybody that again what do you
do um so I work for a nonprofit um I'm
the program manager so I run day-to-day
operations and it is not what I want to
be when I grow up so that's part of the
issue as well okay well so the good
thing is I mean the numbers are not
crazy Shelby you guys don't have
$200,000 of student loans and it's going
to take you8 years you know I mean like
this is doable what you're saying is
like instead of going paying it off in a
year it may take two years because you
have two little kids at home and you
guys are trying to figure out or he goes
I I wonder could he make $1,000 extra a
month yes do that 2,000 if he makes
2,000 I'm not putting this pressure on
him Rachel but if he makes 2,000 a month
through side hustles or something then
he fixes he's fine this issue that he
replaces your take-home so he needs to
make 2,000 after tax and we don't miss a
Beat
theab or Shelby with your Administration
skills like you could do like be an
online assistant for one person for 12
hours a week you you know and it's
something small and you bring in half of
what you're doing just bring in a
thousand be something yes totally and
then he matches it and then you guys do
it or you guys back it off a little bit
and it's 18 months till you pay it off
versus a year like you're okay nothing
is on fire here and we do celebrate the
urgency of getting out of debt on the
show like we we love it because when
people taste that freedom they are like
they're all in right and for some people
it takes them longer because of income
because of stage of life I mean all of
it right so this has to play with who
you are and if you're at this point
where you're like I don't like I don't
like I I I I don't want to do this all
the time like I'm I'm exhausted this is
not fun you know there's going to be
points of that in sacrifice period but
for the long game you don't want that
for the long game so so yeah I mean I
would be great if you guys pulled back a
little bit again like Ken said he if he
could supplement something on the side
just for like two nights a week you do
some assistant work you know be a
virtual assistant bring in a th a month
or something like you guys could you
you're going to be able to get through
this are you guys just curious are are
the cars would you be upside down in the
cars if you sold one or both or what's
the situ that's a good point too yeah so
unfortunately we we bought these cars
When We Were Young and didn't know
anything about money so we're have
negative equity in both of them that's
fine you're going to pay them off is
yeah the plan is to pay them off and
then sell one of them because we don't
need two cars you're great I can tell
you right now Shelby I can sense a
difference in your voice from the start
of the call to now I I think you called
asking for permission you didn't need it
but you got to take care of you and
what's your husband saying what's he
what's he what's his take on all this he
agrees um you know I think he's really
stressed about the amount of debt we
have but at the same time I have I have
a wonderful husband and he really just
to okay yeah me to be okay and the kids
to be okay and hey he can make more
money he can make more money and I'm
telling him you you go watch this on
YouTube Hey listen bro you can make more
money than you're making I know you can
you just got too much skill too much
experience you can take this burden off
your wife it's going to be a win for
everybody uh but you guys are fine and
it's for a year to 18 months to 24
months this isn't forever short time
short
period I kind of miss the screaming baby
face just for about a second come to my
house Ken then I get over it this is the
Ramy
[Music]
show hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly $1 billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me the
phone number is 888 825 5225
5225 and we're taking your questions on
your money and work related questions
feeling stuck sure what to do want to
get a promotion I'm into baby steps how
do I balance all that love to take those
questions as well let's go to Cheyenne
love that name Nashville Tennessee
Cheyenne how can we
help hey guys thank you for accepting
our call so today I was just calling
because first I just want to start we
started the baby steps in December of
2021 so we have
noing or anything besides our house we
have 59,000 left um I'm 21 my husband is
22 and I was just kind of wondering when
we should start having kids I'm ready
now but my husband wants to wait until
we get a couple more things done on the
house just try to wrap things up he also
wants to be more financially stable but
my opinion I mean we're financially St I
mean you know what I mean well it sounds
like you're stable what's your combined
income
um our combined income we make about
5,600 hey are you inside of a tunnel by
any chance we're having a real hard time
hearing you no can you I'm so sorry can
you hear me now yeah perfect maybe stand
completely still and talk like a
ventriloquist to see if we can get that
through so what is your combined income
um well I don't have it all but I know
that we make about 5,000 or
5,600 a month okay and you're both
working correct we are my husband makes
$17 an hour and I make 13 but we're kind
of working on also me changing like
career paths right now I'm a dental
assistant and he works on sewer lines
and Sewer Ms and stuff so what are you
wanting to transition to something
that's
more I don't know like office work or
something I don't really have a set okay
and did I hear you say you guys owe 59
,000 on the house you have nothing
nothing other than that that's the only
debt nothing other than that we'll see
Dave Ramsey in hopefully by by we 30 I
love it our house paid off and can I
presume that you have a fully funded
emergency fund we do we have three
months of us if we don't work it's
funded we have 20,000 in there right now
let me say this I understand your your
hubs I mean he's scared you guys are
really young by the way so get the
provider gland but I'm going to defer to
my friend over here the mama the wife
when they tell them when to have kids
well no it's not your responsibility to
tell them when but what do you think
that what do you think cuz I think you
guys decide what is it what is it he's
worried about yeah well and also
Cheyenne we never and you can tell your
husband this when it comes to kids or
getting married we never tell people you
need to be in a certain Financial spot
so even if you guys had $30,000 student
loans and you wanted to have a baby like
we would tell you like to go on with
your life like financially is it going
to be more stressful there sure but we I
would never not I would never say not to
have kids or not to get married because
of financial reasons I think that you
can work all of that out because
honestly there's never a good time I'm
like you could continue to push that
down um so yeah so my I mean I guess it
would be understanding for you you know
what's what's causing you to want to
have kids now like what is that in you
for him what really is the root of is it
the remodel or is he thinking oh my gosh
I I want to be married three years
without kids and enjoy life and you know
like which are both fine answers but I
think it's more getting down to the
motivation and like what the why behind
wanting to have kids right now yeah so I
do want to add that we've been married
we got married in TW August of 2020 so
we have been married for a little bit we
got married young but that does we act
like old married
couple I appreciate that listen I just
think this is listen you here's the deal
I don't care what the issue is you want
it he doesn't right now yes that's it
and I really think it's because he's
scared anything to do with financial it
has nothing to do with it he's terrified
so what you have to do as his wife you
want something I mean you gotta you got
to get on onto his page for a minute in
order to get him onto your page that
that's all that is to say Hey you know a
nice dinner maybe a romantic weekend or
something and just go hey hey what are
you I want to know um what you're
concerned about and just listen and once
he gets all that out and it's not a
point foro Counterpoint thing it's a
just understand him and hear him and
then express your support for how he
feels and hey you know what would make
you feel comfortable and just talk it
out and I I think I think when he feels
heard and supported and he feels United
with you that you're not forcing a
timeline on him I think things is going
to work out that's what I think I think
it's just a basic easy conversation
about understanding and I think it works
out yes did he say he wanted to have
kids I mean when you guys got married I
mean yes he does want to have kids but
not like right now I would have had them
yesterday I mean yeah I get that and I
think that that's and that's normal too
you guys are not like bizarre people I
feel like that that happens a lot one
spouse is so ready the other one's like
oh so it's it's a little bit of that
you're going to have to compromise that
so your your original question when you
called in is am I being irresponsible no
you're not being irresponsible no on the
financial side or any other side you're
fine you want you're married you want
kids and you know but he doesn't right
now so that's where a little bit of that
grown-up uh conversations have to come
and play and you'll have a lot of them
in marriage of oh yeah welcome one once
one this thing this well we got to get
to the root of what's really going on
how can we each love each other well and
and I think Ken always the advice I
think is so great of seeing something
through his lens what is he seeing what
is he feeling and there's a there could
be a lot there for him which is very
reasonable and so um there's that and
and as always with child you know people
are prepping for kids I'm like and you
never know right it could take you could
have get pregnant on the first try it
could take a year so like even that
journey is a whole journey in of of
itself too so you guys deciding to have
kids it's at least going to be 9 months
till it actually happens at the at the
early that's true at the earliest uh
she's from she's from Nashville Chey if
you like country music pull up a golden
Oldie by Diamond Rio called meet in the
middle the chorus is great I'd start
walking your way you'd start walking
mine we'd meet in the middle Neath that
old Georgia Pine that's the theme I I I
mean as silly as it sounds that's the
play it's a great song by the way uh on
top of that but nonetheless Sandra is in
Boston Massachusetts Sandra how can we
help hello
Sandra Sandra
going once going twice all right we'll
put her on hold we'll see if we can
figure that out but yeah but back to
Cheyenne's you know yeah that is really
it like you you got to meet in the
middle on money discussions children a
lot of stuff and I would yes and I've
heard two different sides of this piece
of advice I'd be curious what you say
I've heard some people say compromise is
the worst word because that means
somebody you both lose or somebody loses
or whatever whatever whatever
interesting um but I think I found I'm
like yeah but there's going to be times
that when someone to do something and I
have to say I don't want to but
selflessly I'm okay I'm going to go and
then same on the other side right
there's stuff that I want to do that
he's like oh jeez another vacation or
whatever you know he's like okay we'll
do it and I'm like thank like there's
give and take in marriage I'm like
there's not going to ever be this
perfect formula whoever said that about
compromise is probably bordering on the
narcissistic side I mean you had to you
had to give something up yeah yeah you
did it's called marriage it's called
well it's it's called I'm going to uh
sacrifice yeah I'm going to serve which
is a form of give you said give and take
I don't think it's that harsh I think it
is you know what um there have been
times in our marriage I'm sure you could
say the same with you and Winston where
Stacy wanted something and there was no
reason not to do it I wasn't there yet
but there weren't any reasons not to
other than I just wasn't as comfortable
as she was y but I shared the value of
number one her desire and the value of
our relationship and it worked out every
time good and I shared the story at
money and marriage that I the second kid
Winston was ready and I wasn't we had
like three trips coming up and zika was
a thing and I was like if I get pregnant
we can't you know we can't go on these
trips and he's like we our life is
dictating our schedule or our schedule's
dictating our life our life needs to
dictate our schedule so it ended up
being this conversation about more our
priori
yeah and then Caroline came 9 months
later and we didn't go on the trips
that's right that's a different story
for a different day that is and she is
as sweet as you think Love Sweet
Caroline she really is she's she's a
doll all right good stuff thank you for
the call um I love that love the young
couples with Big Dreams and making
progress and that couple's an example
don't move more of your calls coming
right up this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramy show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz we're
thrilled that you are with us 888 8825
5225 is the phone number so I've got
something in my hands Rachel that says
ramsy Cyber Monday sale is extended I
mean wow all week all week so you can
get meaningful gifts for the family and
friends as low as $7 Financial Peace
Universities at the lowest price of the
year at only $60 $59.99 you can also get
Junior's Adventure storytime collection
just
$14.99 uh and so much more your books
are in the store my books are in the
store my kids need shoes don't forget
that so we'd appreciate that uh if
you're looking to make a change in 2024
in your professional life to make more
money or just get more meaning uh you
can just check out the Ken Coleman books
of course but the Rachel Cruz wallet I
got to mention that black camel brown
champagne and the brand new Navy I know
we came out with a navy wow that's
pretty nice I could get a Michigan block
him on that and I don't
know yes you could the weekl long Cyber
Monday sale is at Ramy solutions.com
Ramy solutions.com store all right
Sandra we're going to go back to Sandra
in Boston Massachusetts Sandra you're on
the Ramsey
Show Sandra hello hi are you there H yes
I'm there you sound like you made me in
a
tunnel oh I'm right in front of the
window because I I had to move position
can you put your phone up to your mouth
yes my it's right in my it's right in my
mouth oh it's in your mouth that's why
it sounds like you're in a cake I want
you to pull the phone out of your mouth
and put it next to your
mouth all right Sandra we'll try this
hold still what's your
question my question is um I want I'm
interested in buy a purchasing a home
and right now I live in an apartment
purchasing a home then um the mortgage
would be twice as much as my apartment
yeah I live by myself um my child is
grown she's she's not with me and I
wanted to know if it would be a good
idea to purchase a
home um Sandra do you what what do you
make a
month um about $8,000 $9,000 a month
okay and do you have any
debt um I have about 50 45 to $50,000 in
student loan
okay uh do you have any $50,000 in the
bank how much $50,000 in the bank
50,000 yes
great um and then okay so what I would
do Sandra I don't think you're ready to
buy a house right now I would pay off
your student loans today with your
50,000 I would bump up your savings back
up to 3 to six months of expenses and
then take some time to save up a good
down payment after that and then you
just want to make sure even though it's
going to be doubling you know your a a
house payment versus the rent it'll be
double if it works within the formula
that it's no more than 25% of your
take-home pay on a 15year fixed rate
you're fine you're fine just making sure
that math works out so I would not give
you the green light today I would pay
off your student loans today get an
emergency fund of 3 to six months of
expenses back up and say for a good down
payment anywhere from 5 to 20% and make
sure the new house is no more than 25%
of your take-home pay so if those are
the parameters Sandra you're great but
probably not today would I pull the
trigger on that but I would consider a a
different cell phone plan that might be
our first purchase uh let's go to Grant
in San Antonio Texas Grant how can we
help hey how's it going guys um so I am
24 and I just had kind of a massive
change in income in my life in the past
six months so I just wanted some advice
on uh on how to handle this properly um
I was making about $660,000
the year then I got engaged and
immediately got a new job right after
that so where now I'm making around $1
140 to $180,000 a
year good for you come on Grant that's
fantastic thank you guys yeah so I have
I have no car payment I have very
minimal credit card debt because it's
all expensed at the end of the month for
my company um my future wife by fiance
she has a car that probably has about
$8,000 left to be paid off on it uh she
has about3 to $4,000 worth of credit
card debt that we're going to pay off
pretty much immediately when we get
married um my main question is you know
I just I don't want my money sitting
under a mattress and as inflation and
the dollar de value ways I don't want it
to lose value what would be the best
place to put that money to where it can
grow substantially by the time I'm 30 to
35 you know I want to house some kids
and you know be very well off for myself
yeah well it's a great question what
will she be making after you guys get
married she's right right now she's
probably going to keep her job she's
right around 55 to $60,000 a year okay
fantastic I mean you guys are yeah I
mean you you you guys are going be doing
amazing so I would I think paying off
all your debt for sure is is the first
priority and knowing why the credit card
debt was there and all of that right
fixing the the symptom not just the
symptom but the actual problem too um
right but as far as yeah where to put
your money I mean I would I would do a
for sure just a emergency fund of 3 to
six months of expenses and you could put
that in a high yield savings account uh
or a money market account that's not
that's more like insurance money than
Investments and then when you can look
on to investing 15% of your income into
retirement so we look at you know good
mutual funds um to go within that plan
of a 401k or Ral IRA and then beyond
that grants you could always um you know
like CDs don't always keep up with
inflation uh but even just opening a
Vanguard account I'm putting some money
in the S&P 500 is a is a plan that you
could do as well uh but I would always
invest my money when I'm thinking long
term more than five years and making
sure what I'm investing in has a long
track record and so for me again mutual
funds Vanguard account like that those
kinds of things is where I feel the best
putting my money but any short-term
savings that you guys have if you're
saving to buy a house or something again
just just a good high yield savings
account will will I mean some of those
percentages nowadays that's the bad
thing about you know everything going on
with interest rates is if you have debt
it's a ding on you but those of us that
are saving you're like oh dang 6 and a
half% right here doing pretty good and
high yield savings isn't that amazing so
so yeah so all that's keeping up with
inflation so I wouldn't I wouldn't worry
too much I wouldn't park all my money in
a just a regular savings account or a CD
for my whole life but I think you'll do
some investing um and kind of spread
some of that money around is that
helpful yeah no it is and and really
what what we're looking at too is you
know we're both set up in 401K yeah her
company matches 4% my matches 6% so we
have it maxed out so it's free money at
the end of the day sure um really what
we're looking at is right now we're in a
two-bedroom of harband that's costing
about I don't know 1,800 a month we want
to get into a house because we feel like
we're just throwing this money down the
drain every month so we're looking at
probably in the next five to four years
purchasing our first home um
you know I know FHA loan is I think 3%
down so I'm just I'm trying to you know
this is all happening pretty quickly for
me so I want to take my time and do it
the right way for sure I'm just trying
to make sure that I'm making the right
decision of where should I hold this
money you know what type of house should
I be looking at things like that that's
a great question yeah so beyond the
emergency funds yeah saving for a down
payment anywhere um from 5 to 20% and I
would just do a conventional 15year fix
rate and and we always say for the
payment to be no more than 25% of your
take-home pay so that'll give you some
parameters as you guys are saving but
four to five years great you guys should
be great you should be in a in a good
position for sure to buy a house and I
get the renting feeling of like oh my
gosh we're throwing our money away and
that is right I I understand that
feeling but at the end of the day too
you're buying time and it's okay because
you will learn very quickly that home
ownership is very expensive when
everything breaks and stuff happens like
you're on the hook for it all so it
sounds very glamorous and and it's
wonderful right home ownership should be
part of everyone's financial plan long
term um but like you said don't feel
like you have to rush into this I would
be married you guys get married pay off
this debt get an emergency fund in place
start saving for a good down payment um
I would do at least 5% I wouldn't go
lower than five yeah and Grant I would
recommend you go to ramsy solutions.com
after the call and look up some smart
Vestor Pros that are financially uh they
they agree with the ramsy way and going
to help you with that investment
strategy they're going to create a
custom plan for you they're going to
make sure that they share it with you in
a way that you understand it where
you're making the decisions so look up
smartvestor pro at ramsy solutions.com
pick two or three meet with them go with
the one that you feel the most
comfortable with Grant but that's going
to help you on your investment strategy
but you're going to be fine you're going
to in fact you're you're just crushing
it right now yeah congratulations so
excited for it congrats on the gig all
right don't move we got a couple of
commercials coming your way but Rachel
Cruz and I Ken Coleman will'll be back
very soon on the Ramsey Show don't
[Music]
move
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz the
phone number is 888 825 5225 888 825
5225 we're here to answer your questions
let's go to Jason who joins us now in
Los Angeles California Jason how can we
help hey thanks for taking my call sure
what's going on today Jason so I have a
excuse
me I have a u
a sorry I have a ketta that my daughter
wants to plan and um I don't know if you
guys are familiar but gett is pretty
much like a sweet 16 yeah y um we and
I'm I'm in
a bit of a pickle as to whether I could
or I
should um or if I could afford it or
should I do it how much is it going to
cost
so estimated is I'm I'm estima between
10 and
15,000 wow and um you got it itemized
list on that no um another detail on
this is that I'm currently going through
a divorce with her mother and uh this is
kind of being planned by her and these
are their prices kind of of or her
prices as far as what they've found I'm
just trying to see the problem is is
that I have just recently actually fully
funded my six-month emergency
fund but that takes into account any
support that I pay her um my
ex-spouse I don't know if I I'm
technically I can dip into
that but it's an emergency fund and this
is not an emergency yeah not only that
can't afford it you're calling us ask I
the way that you're talking we know you
can't afford it am I right you can't
afford 10 to 15 they're expecting you so
they're planning like she's planning it
and then they're going to expect you to
foot the whole
bill uh not foit the whole bill foot
half she was asking for uh at at the
beginning of all these talks was of half
of it half of 10 which was five but I
don't think that's realistic of what it
would cost I can if I save up until the
point of when this is supposed to happen
I could probably save about
4,000 okay but um I'm just whether I
should do this at this time in my life
like is
is uh Jason do you have any other do you
have any other debt
Jason no or any debt no debt okay but
you're fully funded emergency fund how
much do you make a
year uh over time's been good this year
so it's about at 120 120 okay so here's
my two things that I keep thinking as
you're talking um number one how we
Define an emergency to actually dip into
an emergency fund is when something is
unexpected so this doesn't really
qualify because we know that she's going
to be yeah is it is it is it 16 years
old or is it 15 it's 15 15 yeah okay so
we knew she was going to be turned 15 so
it's not
unexpected uh is it urgent do I have to
do it like right now right now right now
yeah I guess that I guess urgent would
somewhat qualify and cuz there's a date
there and is it necessary right so these
are the two things so honestly this
whole thing it does not check off all
those boxes for me so no it's
technically not an
emergency um so that's that's one part
of the discussion the second part is
that that you could bring together some
money right and let's just say and
pretend that it is 10,000 they want you
to do five you could save four could you
take a th000 out of the emergency fund
to to get to the five sure like you
could right I mean it's not the end of
the world but my my biggest problem with
all of that though Jason is that just
like weddings just like another party
just like vacations anything if you
don't keep a strict budget and have a
limit to what you're going to spend it
gets expensive more expensive I mean a
house even when you build a house same
thing like the line continues to move so
Jason if you decide to do this and to
save the 4,000 for her which I think
would be great right like I don't think
that's a necessarily a bad thing okay
Ken's not that happy about it if you do
it though there has to be very clear
communic and and boundaries with your
future ex-wife to say and and your
daughter I would bring her in on it and
say guys this is the this is what's
going on here's what I will have for you
this is it this is all I can do in good
conscience and in good faith at where I
am in life this is what I
have work with that right and you set
the tone you set the amount on what you
can do Jason because if you tell them
sure I'll do half it's going to go from
10 to 15 to 20 and there's going to be
No Boundaries so you have
okay Ken's dying over here I'm dying I'm
dying I agree with everything Rachel
said I just want to say this I'm going
to try I'm going to I'm going to answer
this if is if I was in your shoes and I
don't I don't know if there's any
special features to this party so I'm
completely ignorant uh but if my
daughter Josie who by the way turns 15
tomorrow um if she came to me and said I
want a big party and I've got a budget I
think it's going to be 10 I would ask
for an itemized list there's no way I'm
even going to give four five six without
seeing where what are the where is the
where in the world is 10 grand going for
a party for a bunch of 15y olds so I'm
starting there um and and so I would say
that everything Rachel said is
absolutely right you give your number
after they give you numbers you don't
just get well it's going to be 10 maybe
12 maybe 15 you give half and and you
you you have to ask for specifics and
have a real conversation with your
daughter and you're in a very tough
situation now with the divorce and now
she's got two don't let the guilt and
don't let the guilt right over that Jon
say baby here's the deal okay give me
your budget what do you want for your
party let's just walk through it let's
teach her this is a teaching moment to
go yeah I'd like to drive a
Lamborghini but I can't and so I know
you want a $10,000 party but guess what
me and Mom can't do a $10,000 party uh
but we can make it an amazing party and
this is how much money I can give
towards an amazing party I think that's
the conversation well it's not I think
that's exactly how I would talk it over
with my daughter jie I'd get her wish
list get real numbers and then how can I
meet her expectations in a much more
budget conscious way I think that's
where you start it takes the pressure
off because now you're dealing in
reality and and then you go look babe
this is what I can do yeah and this
stuff Jason and I know it's such a
cultural part right can see it like I
know that yeah and and I know like you
know um and we I remember we had a guy
call um I think it from India in the
wedding that he wanted to spend was like
half a million dollars right so like I I
totally am aware that there are certain
things culturally that the expectation
is really big but culture should never
out rule common sense but that's it too
so I'm like it's and you could say that
about the American culture right
weddings or whatever like you could plug
in other things so you do have to
there's going to be multiple areas Jason
within you that you're going to have to
be like this oh this is not doesn't feel
right it's not what I wanted but part of
being a grownup to Jason is looking at
the numbers what Ken's saying and it's
like here's just here's the reality
here's the reality of what we have and
what we can or what I have and what I
can do um and so coming back to you
Jason you have a real number in your
head that you feel like I can't afford
you feel like a guy who's in control of
his money situation you sound really
stable what's the number that you go if
I set it on fire for my daughter it
wouldn't bother me it wouldn't give me a
mlock moment what is that
number well right now the the big thing
that is heavy on me is that I haven't
even gotten into my investing portion of
my life for the future I get that but
you didn't answer my question what's the
number that you if you know I can give
this money to my daughter and I'm not
going to lose sleep over
it
um as of now I would say maybe for
something like this 3,000 okay then then
now we've got a starting number I'm
trying to coach you through this
practically you got a number where you
go I know you don't want to spend any
money cuz you think you're behind you're
not you're going to be fine on your
investing you got to weather this
divorce you got to figure out what the
payments are going to be and all that
you're going to restart okay but you're
okay but if the number's 3,000 you go
that's my baby girl she wants this I can
give her three grand then let's start
with that then go get the itemized list
and let's see if we can you know get
closer to it that that's what I'm trying
to do is get you to a point where you
don't let guilt run the day and make a
bad financial decision and I think the
3,000 is a common sense number would you
agree I would say so yeah all right and
your ex-wife's not gonna like it yeah so
prep for that and your daughter may not
like it but she don't like you right now
anyway so we're not losing that deal I
mean I'm not trying to be insensitive
I'm just keeping it real what are you
going to
do make or not want to be married to you
more I mean we've already crossed that
bridge
so you got to stick to your guns man and
uh get the item Jason yeah Jason you're
a good man you're going to be fine it's
going to be a great party yes Rachel by
the way will come do a dance or
something send that request 15y girls
that that'll be great you'll tell a
story this is the
[Music]
re
live from from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions this is the Ramsey show
where we help people win in their life
their money their work and their
relationships I'm Kim Coleman Rachel
Cruz joins me 8825 5225 is the phone
number 8825 5225 Rachel we'll take your
money questions I'll chime in uh if you
got any work related questions you're
just feeling stuck U maybe you want to
make more money in
2024 you want to start a business you
know those kinds of questions they're
all related Rachel's got some great
input on those as well so we're going to
take your calls we'd love to hear from
you Leslie's going to start us off this
hour in Birmingham Alabama Leslie how
can we
help hi um yes so I'm really just
struggling about what to kind of put my
focus on right now um I am trying to
work through the baby steps or at least
kind of develop a game plan um but right
now I'm really not sure how to really
start before I can solve my income
problem um I have ADHD and I know it's a
very common but I guess it's just a big
problem for me specifically um I've had
I've never struggled before if the job
was like active but um you know
professional jobs are usually desk jobs
I got a master's in accounting um I got
a really good job right now but I'm
failing at it because my productivity is
so low because of the ADHD I guess it
just takes me about twice as long as
everyone else um and the two jobs that I
had before this that were gu jobs kind
of were similar and so tell me before we
go any further this is good so was there
a time when you had a job that was not
desk related that you were highly
engaged and you didn't have a
productivity
issue yes well tell me about
it um well honestly it was just you know
restaurant jobs and um things like that
but I've always been promoted in those
jobs and they said I did a really great
job so that tells me I'm not lazy it's
just something something else going on
you know all right so let me address
this and I I have been diagnosed by an
actual psychiatrist I have 8 HD I'm high
functioning so I I've never needed
medication but it does trip me up in a
lot of ways and Rachel could tell
stories and my poor wife and you know so
it is a challenge okay but let me just
say this in general about ADHD because
I've done a lot of reading about
it ADHD can be hyperfocused when you're
doing something that you really enjoy
and the ADHD person everybody by the way
is engaged in something they enjoy
something that they're good at doing but
you take an ADHD person and put them in
a place of of skill and
challenge watch out yes and so you're
absolutely not lazy so this is okay this
is the income side of things you it may
not be waitressing but you have got to
figure out what is the work that I
really enjoy doing and I'm not going to
try to unpack all of this right now but
I'm just going to lay this out for you I
think there's four types of work every
job in the world can be put into four
buckets people work process work idea
work and let's call it object objects or
things okay so that would be working
with your hands building creating
whatever does that make sense those four
areas in
general yes okay great for sure without
so this is to take the pressure off what
what area do you think that that you
would really enjoy because of of of the
the result and you're talented is it
people work process work idea work or
maybe object or things what would you
say well let's see um I guess I'm more
drawn to process or ideas honestly IDE
is the most but I don't see how that
could be an active job don't worry about
that I've coached a lot of people on
this let's just have some fun if you
knew you couldn't fail and we paid you
the amount of money that would be really
really nice you got an idea in your head
what would what would you try in that
idea space because I think you're highly
creative what would you try sure um I
guess I would honestly probably get into
like Health coaching I really love
nutrition and all of that but I just
feel like it's just such a risky um a
risky Venture and I have a four-year-old
son got my single mom and so I just I
can't I can't do anything risky totally
got it totally got it but we're not
talking risk right now we're talking
your future all right so here's what I
would tell you um I think you're a
people person because you know you
really enjoyed be you said you were on
your feet uh but you were waiting tables
and the idea of being a nutrition or
health coach is highly people and highly
processed and uh okay yeah I you you you
have a heart for helping people don't
you you enjoy stepping in and giving
people maybe a light bulb moment yes or
no yes all right now here's what I want
you to do okay I want to talk through
your money want race it to walk through
your money situation but I'm going to
give you a couple of tools at the end of
the phone call I'm going to give you the
get clear assessment I want you to take
it 15 minutes and it's really going to
validate what you're feeling and and and
I'm going to give you the book that goes
with it from paycheck to purpose how do
we actually get there to where that's
not risky as a single mom with a
four-year-old okay so those are my gifts
and Christian I know you're listening at
the end of the call if we need to
schedule a call uh for Leslie to come on
my show where we can go deeper we'll do
that how's that does that sound good
lesie yes yes sir that is amazing I
actually wanted to take that assessment
thank you so much it's my gift to you uh
because I I think you're closer than you
realize last point on this I think that
that there's a very clear path to where
you get qualified you you may have to be
patient and to get to a point where we
cash flow the qualification but that you
can get a good job in the Health
Nutrition physical coaching space I
think it's wide open for somebody like
you to do pretty well uh but I want
Rachel to jump in on your finances right
now because part of making this step
forward towards this work is getting
yourself financially stable to pay for
the qualification that's right for sure
so lesie how much debt do you
have I have 100 100K 100,000 75 yeah 75k
in student loans and uh this is going to
seem you know almost hypocritical sort
of but I have $25,000 in debt because of
Health stuff because my son has some
health issues and I've just been you
know I felt like I knew how to you know
help him but I overspent on those areas
um by like you know buying you know
really good food and things like that so
totally but I'm to my senses I'm just
trying to get out of the hole so 25,000
in credit card debt so it's credit cards
but but it attributed to health
situations yes and 75k um for the St
loan okay perfect and how much are you
making in your current
job my current job is 70k which I'm
really grateful for but like I said I
don't feel like I have a lot of job
security right now well let me jump in
really fast on this you have got to
switch your mind set I know the 8 ADHD
is real but you cannot go backwards
right now this you you either replace
this job with another $70,000 job that
you can focus or you overcome this you
you figure this out cuz you can but you
have to focus you're a mama bear and
that little boy and getting out of debt
matters you got to have this income yep
so fix it I know you can it's yeah and
you and you're in a great uh I know the
the actual career path is not your
favorite as an accountant but that's a
but that's a great stable degree to have
and you know skill set to have that
people need that so like you can plug in
do that and lesli and I would even say
um which is just exhausting but is if
there's any way to get some level of
more traction income wise to give you a
level of confidence so even if it's you
know um doing like admin work for
another company 8 hours a week or be a
virtual assistant for 6 hours a week for
someone like if you can find another
level of supplemental income to attack
cuz this 10 this
$100,000 and $25,000 in credit card debt
I mean you any any amount of income that
you have that can be thrown at that
obviously is going to be great and yeah
and the health stuff with the 25,000 I
think that as a mom we we do we want to
help our kids and when Health stuff
comes in the picture it's very scary but
I want you to be very Discerning have
people around you speaking into these
decisions so you don't go deeper in that
hole you're awesome you can do this mama
bear we believe in you this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey show a
conversation about your life your money
your work your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me I got to
say this it's always fun one of the the
neat things about doing the show uh at
our world headquarters here just south
of Nashville uh is we have an awesome
Lobby and we tell you to come watch the
show great group of people uh the entire
time what are you laughing at James is
laughing at Rachel started laughing
first world headquarters right up there
with tollfree it's it's kind of it's
right up there it's a little
Dramatical our International head I
didn't say that I said world
headquarters by the way am I wrong it is
true it's factually correct thank you
very much I I know I'm listen I'm given
to
exaggeration this is just let it go you
guys act as though I've never
exaggerated before so shocking it was it
was such a good open to the show I was
about ready to talk about the nice
people in the lobby and Rachel and James
are making fun of me I'm going to suck
my thumb after the show it's not good
I'm going to be in a therapy chair over
this I hope you all are enjoying our
world headquarters here at ramsy
solution back to what I was saying look
at these people there they are if you
come to our world headquarters there's a
lobby as you might expect at our world
headquarters you would think you'd have
a decent Lobby and we have free drinks
free food uh so there there you go Mrs
smarty pants I love it I know I do too
by the way she was telling me on a break
James that sometimes people go in the
comments on YouTube and say they they
don't think Rachel and and me get along
or George doesn't matter who they
diagnose our like friendships like oh
you can tell no if can't tell that
Rachel and Ken like each other aren't
really friends you you are not very
aware you you lack discernment we having
a lot of fun right now she's not being
mean to me at all now James is but
that's a different deal all right let's
go to Tyler in Flint Michigan Tyler how
can we help hey there um so I had a
question I've listen to you guys a lot
you guys don't like whole life insurance
three um three years ago I got into it I
thought it was a good investment I pay
$75 a month for
$175 whole life
insurance
um I thought it was a good investment
you know because like say when I retire
in 25 years um I'd have that little tump
of money that I could utilize and I'd
only be I think it's just under $15,000
into
it and I could utilize that whole life
insurance per se on my property or
something like that um and then leave a
little remainder for in case but um I
guess you guys are against it and I'm
wondering what I should do instead of
that should I do a different insurance
or going to like a high index yeah I
would um so Tyler yeah so the reason the
my biggest reason with whole life
insurance that I hate is mixing your
investments in your insurance and the
rate of return in these policies is
terrible versus if you went and just
opened up your own mutual fund or
Vanguard account and did an S&P 500
Index Fund like you could make so much
more money so much more money out in the
market versus it being stuck in this
whole life policy so what I would do is
I would go to Xander insurance this is
where my husband and I get our insurance
because they're the best they shop
multiple policies not just one company
and get a term life policy and it's you
know anywhere from 10 to 12 times your
annual income and it's going to be cheap
you're going to fund it annually or
quarterly however you set up the
payments and then look at investing at a
complet
separate way right so investing 15% of
your income into retirement after you
have paid off all of your debt and have
an emergency fund in place and those
kind of things so investing in Insurance
should never go together when they start
going together you're getting a bad deal
because you could just do so much more
with your investment out in the
marketplace okay that's kind of what
I've been understanding listening to you
guys every day on my way home yeah so
but but I will say keeping life
insurance because I'm assuming you have
a family and kids that depends on your
income right
yeah yeah so before you cancel your
whole life make sure to go ahead and get
the term life in place and then cancel
your whole life because God forbid you
cancel the whole life and something
happens and you don't have policy in
place so yeah so make sure you do that
but yeah just go to Xander insurance and
that's what Winston and I do and it's so
in I can't remember what we pay it's so
inexpensive yeah I got I'm so insured
that I don't sleep well at night because
I think Stacy might you know do little
if I don't have a good attitude that day
little Lifetime movie action
K go Miss yeah and I'm gone yeah and the
kids are loving life man this is one
sector of money that George camel if he
was walking by right now we'd wave him
in cuz he would rant and rant on this
stuff because it is part of this product
this financial product is really what it
is that they sell it's all over
Instagram reels and Tik Tok and
financial advice and people are like
well you can actually use your life
insurance while you're alive that's what
rich people it's all this gimmicky stuff
you guys and at the end of the day it
it's not good for your money I'm like it
just look at the annual
return of those mutual funds and how
they performed over a lifetime just do
your own homework on it and then compare
to the numbers they're going to give you
just on the numbers alone it's just not
even close and and Winston and I did
this because we had a friend this was
years ago and their grandfather set them
up with a whole life which was again
great intention sure for 18 years got
the policy and if he had invested that
just in a mutual fund oh it make your
stomach T it does I mean it really just
do your own homework and look at the
numbers folks this is not our opinion y
uh these are facts let's go to Sebastian
who joins us by the way I think
Sebastian's a great fantastic name if my
name were Sebastian Coleman I'd be a big
deal I think so I really do Sebastian is
on the line in Phoenix Sebastian how can
we help oh my God hey thank you um
what's it called so my question is uh I
have I guess like a month Gap until
January to I guess move out to my
friend's house but move out from
where uh my mom and dad's house oh
they're kicking you out no so uh they my
friends have a open room and they're
only giving me a month Gap to decide if
I want to move out or
not but I already know my mom and dad
don't like them because they smoked
so I'm just trying to think what's
probably the best way to approach trying
to tell them that I want to move out to
their house per se yeah how old are you
Sebastian 22 okay do you have a job yeah
I work at the post office okay how much
do you make a
year uh after tax 40K okay and can you
support yourself fully or you depended
upon them
financially um no I could for sure I
could depend on myself and only myself
well that your mom and dad don't get a
vote they they they they don't get an
actual vote here now I would kind of AG
I mean you know Wise I mean they
probably have some wisdom in life so if
they're like are these guys smoking I
mean uh is this a bigger problem than
just what they're
smoking I mean not really that's like
the only reason why they just don't want
me to move out with them the rent's
cheap it's only 600 a month so yeah I
think it's one of these things Sebastian
you to decide is this the kind of house
I mean honestly and I don't even want to
ask on air I'm going to I'm going to
pretend you know because if it's
cigarettes smoke and they're smoking
house is gross I know I'm just saying
the SM the the life I know I'm just
saying the St the smell of it I don't
want to live in a house where people SM
are are they smoking the weed in the
house that's the million dollar question
yeah dude is that where you want to live
or do you want to here let me ask you
this way personally I'm going to give
you a multiple choice do you want to
live with these guys who are smoking
weed in the house and whatever else
comes with that behavior all right uh
for $600 a month because it's a great
deal or do you want to just get out on
your own and get away from Mama and Dad
because you're 22y old grown you know
what man so which do you want
more A or B I guess B yeah then do that
you're acting like that's the only
option like living with a bunch of
smokers is your only
option yeah true I
know so I mean you've got a false
narrative here like this is my only
option live at home with Mom and Dad
some options you make decent money you
know so do your
homework okay you can find an apartment
between now and January 1st and get a
roommate find a roommate or two yeah
yeah I don't smell and the only my bad
but the only reason why I'm not really
too concerned on if I don't move out
with them till January it's just they
don't my mom and dad don't charge me
even a rent yeah but you're you're
you're a 22-year-old man with a job you
need to be out on your own seriously bro
come on you got to get out you're you're
a grown man act like it it's going to be
wonderful you're going to be fine mom
and dad are there they're speed dial
away don't move in with these guys
whoever are these guys di free worldwide
head free number get a free number for
your mom he send them a facts this is
the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me we're here
for youle
88255 225 taking your money questions
your work questions let's go to Molly
now in San Antonio Texas Molly how can
we
help hey Ken hey Rachel so good to talk
to you good to talk to you what's going
on well um about a year and a half ago
we put our kid into private school um
and I'm sorry I'm a little bit nervous
um you're doing great so yeah uh my
husband's a real estate
agent and uh you know we've had a slow
couple of months I guess probably since
September we haven't had a closing um I
make about $110,000 a year um and
private school bill is starting to
become a bit daunting not really sure if
we can cover anymore so wanted to talk
to
somebody that's
stressful how old are your kids
uh 11 Nine and Nine of twins okay so
those are uh is that third fifth grade
sixth grade uh yeah um fourth fourth and
sixth okay yep
yep uh how much is the school because
three kids three tuitions I know in
Nashville schools
it's yeah um it comes yeah it comes to
be about um 27 total okay 27,000 okay
per year yeah okay for all three yep
okay and the dentals but that's usually
what it comes out to sure okay and have
you guys paid for the rest of the school
year already did you do anything upfront
or do you pay month-to month how does
that work uh it's a month-to month it
goes into the summer as well oh okay
okay and your
husband is doing real estate it didn't
have a closing in September so that's
you're feeling the pinch of that does he
have things coming up does he how how
was his forecast looking with his
pipeline yeah it's there's some stuff
down the road probably not until um
April or June so um but obviously you
know's he's really trying so we sure
it's just get you know we've got we've
got an emergency fund um most of it's
tied up in equities um which are in the
red so I'm a little I'm a little afraid
to sell them what do you mean your
emergency fund is tied up in equities
it's tied up in a house oh oh no I'm
sorry um
securities Investments your your
emergency fund
is yeah most of it most of it's in
mutual funds but we do have a bit of it
in stock okay okay so I would Molly I
would I think part of feeling secure is
knowing that there is money there
regardless of what the economy is doing
right so that's why we always say to
have three to six months of expenses in
just a high yield savings or a money
market account something that's not
invested because we say it's not an
investment so for you and your husband
tonight I mean this weekend I would
really have the conver ation of hey what
would it look like just to get some cash
to the side that's secure regardless of
what the market up and down it's there
that may give a level a piece and I
understand it's in the red and all of
that you're going have to look at it but
that's that's one uh step I would make
do you guys have any
debt no other than the mortgage we don't
okay um yeah I mean I think it's just
one of these conversations Molly you
guys have to figure out if he's not
bringing in an income right now is there
anything else he can be doing on the
side to make some kind of money uh how
how much is private school valued to you
guys you know is it is it a big value
because some people will sacrifice other
parts of their lifestyle like they won't
go on vacation they won't do certain
things in order to provide private
schooling for their kids because of
where they live or religious you know
convictions or learning situations or
you know whatever it may be so I think
it's a very personal choice but also we
can't um go into the red in your budget
month to month either right so there
there is common sense that has to play
in and is the amount of stress that's on
you guys worth it for the private
school so absolutely what what is the
reasons for the private school can I ask
sure um you know we're just we're
District in a in a some schools in my my
my daughter's Middle School was the one
that really worried me so um you know we
thought we could just bring her but then
we figured out you know with all the
driving and everything we're just like
let's just put all three in yeah um cuz
at some point we knew that the that the
twins would have to go to that middle
school as well so we you know so your
local schools okay yeah so your local
schools is not great so you're yeah
choosing for Education okay perfect no
that's good it's good to know um yeah I
mean I mean Molly it's one of those
things if if you guys can't pay it if
you can't afford it then understood you
you can't afford it but um also with
110,000 of just you bringing in that
money which is great money so if he is
not doing closings I mean Ken I mean I
would say he needs to be bringing in
some income that's where I was going to
go Molly I I uh I I don't want to be
insensitive but if he doesn't have a lot
of listings and I I read something this
morning that housing sales are as low as
they've been in quite some time almost
two decades and so if he doesn't have
prospects he's got time yes or no yeah
then he needs to be working and so what
is that number you may have given it to
Rachel what is the number that would
cover just the the private school what's
that monthly
number um I think it came out to about
1,300 a month okay if I were him if I
were in your shoes and you really wanted
those kids there and I knew that he was
in a cycle right now that's going to
cycle back but I would be
making more than $1,300 a
month I would be making enough to take
care of the private school to keep the
kids in the school even if I got to work
a side job I'm doing whatever it takes
to keep keep him in there it maybe a
career shift Molly I mean how long has
he been a real estate agent
for um well you know he's had his
license for a while but he went
full-time Realtor about a year and a
half ago uh about two years ago almost
um so yeah there's still some some
options on the back burner that we could
fall back on it was it was more of the
the income potential is really what
keeps us going so you know it's just
there there could be a great month there
could just yeah I don't think he walks
away I think he gets Innovative right
now and Innovation you know is when we
don't have a of resources and we got to
come up with something and I think he
can come up with the money I I would not
touch the emergency fund this is not an
emergency at all um even if you had to
tell the school hey look here's our
situation give us one month uh Grace and
we'll pick up the payments I mean there
there's things that can be done here if
it's that close um so handle this you
know um like an adult and go if you got
to communicate to the school a little
bit on this but he needs to he needs to
to go make the $1,300
somebody does makes
sense you know I wish I had some Grand
strategy but that's what it boils down
to and while the while the real estate
uh economy is is tight right now uh
there's other ways that he can make
money in San Antonio Texas and and and
easily come up with that
amount that's if okay all caps if we
really want to keep those kids in the
school where there's a will there's a
way is the old saying and I think that's
true
you know yes sir trust your gut M it's
hard though I know Molly and it feels I
mean the tension is there because I'm
like oh my gosh he hasn't had a closing
money's not coming in it's dependent
upon you I mean there's a level of that
pressure on your shoulders Molly um that
you're probably feeling too and you
don't want to take your kids out of the
school I mean like there's so many
Dynamics here but $1,300 a month is I
mean it's doable right it's very doable
if I know that I'm making this money on
the side y just to keep my kids in a
private school and and out of a bad
school situation I like the chances of a
mom and dad who are willing to come
together and go how do we come up with
$1,300 yep and that's part of you know
as we talk about your budget and life
decisions that you make in life you know
everything that's the part of like we're
adults everyone gets to decide what you
want your life structured right and
where this family says yeah we're going
to take on extra work to keep our kids
in a private school that's what they're
choosing you know you talk to people and
they have one income family cuz the Mom
they're choosing for her to be home
homeschooling the kids and that's what
they're choosing you have two people
careers and they're doing that like it
is so much about choices and the values
of the individuals and the families and
that always gives me a level of Peace
where we do have some black and white
principled things here at ramsy we do
say you know you need to be on a budget
all these things that are helpful but
the details of how you live out your
life and your money it's up to you you
get to decide right there's hundreds of
different options of of which track you
want to take in life and you get to
decide that so um if Molly and them
that's what they want they're adults and
they get to decide that so now you have
to figure out okay how are we going to
make this work and then you got to make
some adult decisions around that yeah
absolutely you guys are going to figure
it out Molly it's going to be okay it's
going to cycle through do what's best
for you guys do whatever it takes to do
what's best for the family we know you
will thank you so much for the call all
right she's Rachel Cruz I'm Ken Coleman
you're listening to the Ramsey Show
don't move more coming up
[Music]
thank you for joining us here on the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz
joins me we're thrilled that you're with
us 88255 225 is the phone number our
scripture of the day comes from G Ians
1:0 am I now trying to win the approval
of human beings or of God or am I trying
to please people if I were still trying
to please people I would not be a
servant of Christ Our quote today from
Jordan Peterson compare yourself to who
you were yesterday not to who someone
else is today h there you go you talk a
lot about comparison feels like that's
right up your alley yeah it's a good
quote there you go let's go to Ivy now
in Baton
Rouge Ivy how can we help hello hey
thank you all for having me you bet how
can we help yes uh wondering if you can
help me settle a debate between me and
my wife oh my favorite thing to do is
get in the middle of a marriage
debate I bet yall are okay well we both
found our uh dream home which is about
an hour away from where we currently
live um I want to we have some rental
properties and our home that we live in
I want to liquidate everything and pay
for this new house cash that way we'll
be debt free totally debt free except
for a car note maybe and um then take
the extra money that we will have and
maybe do Investments uh where we live
where we going to live at
next do that making sense yep it does
she wants to keep she wants to keep the
two mineral properties because she
thinks that the extra income every month
is going to help us down the way okay
have you run the numbers to where you
take her Theory and we get it out on
paper and we go okay if we keep this
this is this is this extra revenue and
you look at her financial decision and
then you look at yours have you run
those numbers side by side yes sir and
uh she still wants to keep the she still
wants to keep that the rental income cuz
yours is clearly better your your option
is better on paper yeah you know the the
rental income equals out to about $2,700
a month um but we're all we're doing
with that money right now is taking that
money putting it down on our mortgage so
the mortgage company can take the
interest and they make money off of it I
want to keep that money for ourselves
right right I'm with you so how far and
how far will you guys move from the
rental properties it's it's about an
hour away a little bit over an hour so I
mean it's doable to keep those
properties there and still maintain them
and still and now we both have full-time
jobs also so it would be a little
difficult to you know go get rent if is
leaking Ivy what's her reasoning for
wanting to keep them is it just the
rental income or is there something that
she loves real estate that she it's she
found the deal like I don't know is
there any main reason she she she thinks
that the that the extra $2,700 a month
trumps everything coming in I said well
if if if everything we own is paid for
we won't need the $2,700 a month coming
in we can we we would have $2700 a month
of our own money to put extra
Investments and do whatever we want you
know yeah because what would the
mortgage be on the new house the dream
house if you were to take out a mortgage
yeah the mortgage on the dream house uh
if we well we she does want to liquidate
our home that we live in now and we
bought it well and uh we bought low and
we're going to sell pretty high so we
make a good amount of money off of it
but the note would still be anywhere
from $2,000 to $2,200 a month on the new
plate right so it's kind of a wash in
that in just that regard yes yes is she
putting her foot down saying sorry pal
it's my decision or we still discussing
this back and forth how tension filled
is this
and we we uh you know uh they say
marriage is 5050 but I don't believe
that it's it's usually one person that
gives more and that person is me and I
love that though I'm not I'm not angry
or mad about it at all uh we you know we
have a real good relationship we work
real hard to get where we at and I think
this is a good problem to have um but
it's we're leaning more towards now we
still discussing it because it ain't all
went through yet uh we're still
discussing it but we're leaning more
towards hey keeping the rental
properties and just taking the profit
from the house we live in now putting it
down on the new house and paying the
$2,200 a month you know how much do you
have left on the rental properties how
much do you owe on them one of the
rental properties is completely paid for
it's worth about 100 it's worth about
150 Grand okay the other the other
rental property uh we only owe like
33,000 on it and it's worth about 225 to
250 okay why don't you sell one of them
why don't you sell the one that you
still have a payment on because she
wants them both yeah she wants them both
yeah she you didn't answer my question
$700 a month profit is there tension
over this or is she
open-minded no it's not tension but uh
you know I don't think it's going to go
my way way well I can tell you right now
it's not going to go your way I I but
you know what this is tough man I if are
you sure you won't resent her over this
because there's a good chance that she
gets tired of being a long-distance
landlord yeah yeah well no I won't
resent over it because uh nothing
matters to me but her happiness so uh
all right and that's and that's that's
truth that's not me just saying that
because I'm on the radio then why'd you
call us and ask us to uh take sides I'm
not asking you to take sides I might be
coming back with a little bit of an
argument towards her you know just to
say hey look I called a Ramy show and
they said this would be a better idea to
do it this way but it is a better idea
and I think you showed her that but I I
don't think that I don't think that this
is enough of a compelling case for her
to to come off of her position yeah cuz
I mean and also you know Ivy how much do
you make a year how much I make a year
yeah or you guys together household
income oh household I make about 110 15
a year she makes 150 a year so she is
the bread winner of the family okay and
how much is the dream and how much can
you sell your current home for like how
much will you walk away with we can walk
away with about 200,000 okay and the
dream home cost how much 325 oh well
you're fine okay so I if she wants to
keep the houses keep the houses because
you only owe
$33,000 on the second rental yes so so
yeah you're not far off on a mortgage
take out a small mortgage on the dream
home pay off the dang car you said you
had a car loan pay that off today Ivy
you need to pay that off work to pay off
this rental property you have two paid
for rental properties um and then attack
your and then attack your primary
mortgage yeah I
this isn't a really yeah this isn't like
really one way the other I like your
playing a little bit more but I do too
but you guys are in great financial
position if you do what Rachel says you
put a huge down payment do you have any
savings oh yeah we got 16,000 in savings
right now and then I have a 401K with
okay close to a million dollars in it
for heaven sake keep absolutely do what
makes her happy ivy keep the 16,000 as
your emergency funds pay off the car
that needs to be Next Step yeah you can
take the small mortgage on the dream
home off that second house and now
second house now you guys are you guys
have got real estate and use the 2700
from her point to help pay off the new
house sooner yeah yeah I'm going to
change my ruling iy interest would would
be paying you know so I know Ivy I'm
changing my ruling if I were you Ivy I
would do your way then Winston and I did
that we sold we had two rental
properties we sold in order to build the
house that we're in now and so like
that's what we chose to do cuz we didn't
we were not living with debt so like
that was a hard Line in the Sand for us
um but you guys mathematically it's not
like crazy off you can do this no happy
wife happy life is my philos that's my
vote I I I guess but also like no I I
just don't think he's gonna we've
already asked I don't think he's going
to move her off the position at all and
uh they're in such good financial
position it's not worth fighting over
right right now she may get tired the
question is is who's going to get more
tired of the hour distance between the
new home and these homes cuz that is
that's a that's a pain in the butt being
a landlord but uh you got option I
didn't want to stop you know we we
flipped houses in the past you know we
were very handy we can we do a lot of
work on our own homes and stuff like
that so I wanted to start all over again
where we at take the extra money we have
left buy some little houses over here
and keep doing did she do any of the
work on these houses you said we she's
right next to me no she's right next to
me every time we do something this is
the passive aggressive play but you
could have her go and fix some of those
things the first couple months your way
and see if she likes driving an hour to
fix it it's your only shot man it's your
only shot my only shot boss I think so
hey I'm keeping it real man I've been
married 25 years I'm with you you got to
go with the woman on this one I just
hate that phrase Happ I don't why do you
hate that you benefit from it what's
your problem because it's a little bit
like oh I'm going to just be this the
run over the M I'm just going to be here
and she's going to take over and I don't
know I'm like I think you're reading
into that give a little like I think
happy wife happy life is very positive
it doesn't say I'm a beat down broken
man I know it's that's said that's been
said so many times on this show today by
multiple men happy wife happy life say
it again I think it's true I think
Winston would say it too we'll discuss
it we'll discuss it off the air folks
we'll see she's Rachel Cruz I'm kid
Coleman big thanks to our captain old
Captain my Captain James Charles this is
the Ramy
show
[Music]
n